So it's my pleasure to
introduce Arielle Berry,
who is the founder and CEO of Mobile Odt.
He's here to talk about catching
cancer using AI enabled smartphones.
A round of applause for him please.
Thank you very much. Thank you
everybody. And thank you so much for
joining me today and for inviting me.
Thank you Ilana for this wonderful
opportunity to share with you a little bit
about what we're doing.
And my goal for today is to share with
you a bit of what is possible using
today's technologies. Um, not
so much from the technical side,
but more from the structural side.
I'm happy to speak
afterwards during the Q and,
a if you have want to go
a little bit deeper, but,
but what I would love to speak with you
about today specifically is about health
care and,
and on a fundamental level,
what health care requires more
than anything else is information.
So, um, when I started, uh,
Mobile Ott together with
my cofounder David Levitz,
one of the things that we were
struggling with was we had on one hand,
it's technology,
which was a under understanding
their consumer electronic devices.
We're getting so much better thanks to
the rise in mobile phones and we had a
need out there. Um, we
identified that cervical cancer,
which we'll speak about in a bit,
is a leading cause of death for women
in rural areas around the world.
And it was so easily treatable.
But connecting the two was the question
that we faced and what we realize this
is part of the,
uh,
the conversation that we had with some
of the world's leading public health
organizations around the world was that
in the end on the most fundamental level
healthcare and the provision of
good healthcare depends on data.
And that's something that all of you
and definitely Google knows a lot about.
So if I can leave you with two things
at the end of this presentation,
the first one is that health care
depends on information on data.
And then the second thing is that
mobile computing will make healthcare
accessible to every person on the planet.
So with those two particular things,
I'd love to jump into the presentation,
share a little bit about what we do
and then hopefully engage with you in
conversation about how you might be
able to use your superpowers in terms of
your abilities as engineers,
as business people,
as operations people to save as
many lives as quickly as possible.
So I'll step back.
My name is Arielle Berry.
I have the absolute pleasure to be here
today to represent a company called
Mobile Odt mobile optical
detection technologies.
And what we do on the most fundamental
level is use the power of mobile phones
to address disease.
Now there are a lot of different ways
that mobile phones can be used to address
disease.
Some companies use apps that consumers
will use to track their blood sugar or
their blood pressure and
intervene on a daily basis.
What what we believe as a company and
where we're seeking to contribute is in
prevention.
So good healthcare is best suited
to do preventable diseases,
right?
If you can catch a disease,
almost any disease while
it's early enough to treat,
you can clearly and quickly treat
it before a person gets to ill.
And so you can save years of personal
lives and thousands of dollars and
families going into debt just by
identifying disease early enough.
And we believe that the people who are
best suited to currently empower with
such technology is our health
care workers. And our mission,
our mission as a company is
to equip healthcare workers,
the nurses, the midwives,
the technicians,
the clinicians that are out there serving
the majority of humanity on a daily
basis to equip them with the tools that
they need to be able to provide better
care.
And if we look at that as a mission,
then the question becomes as a company,
where can we make the most impact?
And so we decided,
um,
to take dedicated caregivers to provide
them with mobile compute labs and to
help them make an evolutionary jump in
their ability to provide health care
quality,
particularly in cervical cancer.
So many of you already know this,
but I just want to make sure
that we're all on the same page.
Cervical cancer is a leading cause of
death for women in rural areas around the
world.
It's a cause of death that is in many
ways the most tragic because the most
preventable, I'll show you in a little
bit how cervical cancer develops,
but just on on one foot,
cervical cancer can take up
to 20 years to kill a patient.
It comes from an infectious disease,
the HPV, the human papilloma virus,
and if you catch it within
the first five years,
you can treat it on the spot with
basically the equipment you have in the
kitchen for less than 28 bucks
and less than 20 minutes.
So how can it be that a disease that is
easier to cure than the flu is killing
millions of women to decade mothers,
pillars of their community? How?
How is that possible? It's actually
one of the fascinating things.
It's because women aren't screened.
So every woman,
every single woman of reproductive age
should be screened for cervical cancer
regularly, whether it be every
three years or every five years,
depending on the technologies
that we have available.
And yet the majority of women
around the world aren't.
And all it has to do is that one moment
of screening and that one moment of
identification of disease in which a
woman's life can go from the death column
two, the life calmed. Now,
what's fascinating is that despite the
investment in maternal and child health,
since 2015 since recently,
cervical cancer deaths have become more
prevalent than deaths from maternal and
child complications.
So it's one of those things where it's
just a little bit of investment in
regular screening can mean millions
of women alive to take care of their
families. And that's not a problem
just around the world's problem.
Also in America, almost every person in
reproductive age in this room, for sure,
and many of the people who'll be watching
online will at some point in their
life contract the HPV virus.
Human Papilloma virus is one of
the more popular viruses today,
and 79 million Americans are
living with it at this moment.
And what that virus does
is it infects the cells.
The cells that are infected with high
risk strains of that virus will start to
become inflamed, and then
they will develop a disease.
And if you catch it early,
treat it. And if the body's immune
system can, can flush it out,
it'll flush it out.
Just like we flush out viruses every day.
But for some Americans, and for many
women around the world, the kills them.
Now, the way it works is as follows,
and apologies for the graphic images,
but I think it's important to recognize
because it is a visually accessible
disease. So a normal cervix, the cervix,
just for everyone who I learned
this when I started, uh,
at mobility of the cervix is where the
baby comes out through, right? So it's,
it's, it's part of the woman's anatomy
and the cervix, a normal cervix is, uh,
is fleshy and has squamous cell and uh,
and Kolmar sells. I asked.
The virus infects those cells,
they start to become inflamed and
visibly on the surface of the cervix,
you start to see signs that that infection
is becoming is beginning to grow.
Right at that stage at precancerous stage,
you can still just cut out those cells,
literally freeze them
out or burn the mountain.
A procedure that can take
a few minutes using very,
very simple technology
that can be done anywhere,
literally anywhere around the world.
And that woman will go from the
death column two, the life calm.
But if you let it persist,
then infection continues and those
cells invade, then you get cancer.
And at that stage it is almost
impossible to save a woman's life.
So you have this very long process that
can take up to 20 years where from a
normal cervix to a precancerous cervix,
you have a five year window.
And even during that period of
precancer you can still treat easily.
Now what's fascinating is that
screening is only part of the problem.
So anyone who looks at
graphs will generally look
at this graph and say, well,
wait a second, the trends
are going down, but I want,
what I want you to notice is that
from around the year 2000 until today,
despite the fact that we've introduced
tremendous technological leaps in
cervical cancer screening,
liquid based cytology,
HPV testing, and most
importantly, the vaccine,
the number of deaths and the number
of new cases have basically flatlined,
right? They have not gone to zero,
which is what you'd imagine, right?
All of a sudden we're vaccinating
people and we're screening with better
technologies and we're
intervening when we can. No,
we're still seeing thousands of women
develop the disease and thousands of women
die from the disease in America.
Forget outside of the United States
where those rates are growing every year
because infection rates are, are growing.
So the question then becomes, all right,
so we have all these
wonderful technologies,
liquid based cytology and
HPV testing and vaccination,
and hopefully everyone in the,
everyone listened to here is vaccinated.
Why is this technology?
Why are we not yet able to stop
such a simply stoppable disease?
Well has to do with lack of experts.
So I like showing the map of the United
States as opposed to the map of India or
China or Africa because it's so striking.
The red is where there
are zero gynecologists.
These are counties of the
United States of America,
one of arguably the most developed and
economically successful countries in the
world.
And that is the map of lack of expertise.
So if you catch the disease,
what are you going to go?
Okay,
let me tell you something that's actually
fascinating. When I learned that I,
it blew my mind, 25% of
women, one quarter of women,
one out of four women who were called up
and told you have a positive high grade
lesion from your pap smear,
you need to come in and get treated.
Do not return.
Half of women who were called up and said,
you have a high grade HPV test,
high risk HPV at us.
You got to come in for your next, for
your next appointment. Don't come in.
And the question is why? Because
the distance. And so the,
and again this is an America where you
have great roads and you have Amtrak and
you have buses and you have the
ability to get places in theory, right?
Forget rural Africa or rural India,
rural Southeast Asia.
So the,
the problem,
the challenge is the connection of
the patient and the expert and that's,
that's what we sought to address.
So,
so this is the enhanced visual
assessment system. This is eva.
Eva is built around the technology
that all of us, no one love
the android mobile phone,
right?
The amazing thing about the technology
that this company that Google has
contributed so much towards and that
we as consumers have supported and its
growth is that it's become so powerful
and its ability to capture images,
process and analyze those images and
communicate with a world of expertise that
is on the Internet,
right?
The things that we know and love from
everyday interactions are actually
critical to health care provision.
And what that means is that those nurses,
those midwives,
those technicians that do see the
majority of humanity by using a device,
a medical device of FDA cleared CE marked
medical device that was enhances the
power of the mobile phone can now provide
expert treatment wherever that woman
is. So anywhere that you can take your
phone, you can take any of his system,
but obviously it's not just the mobile
phone and it's not just the device,
it's that what eva does and devices
like it, connected devices like it is,
it connects the cloud to the patient at
the point of care and it connects the
patient or the point of
care and the provider,
the healthcare provider at the
point of care to the cloud.
And that's what's so powerful
about the moment that we're in.
And that's why there's such a moment of
potential for all of us to contribute.
Because once we recognize that in essence
solving healthcare challenges is a
solving a data problem.
It means that every time
that we impact health care,
we can literally transform the way that
healthcare services are provided through
connecting dots,
through connecting pieces of information.
Now we've learned this and, and
I, I'm, I'm going to stop the,
the mobile Lutie t segment for a second.
We've learned this by working nine
to 29 countries around the world,
a lot in the United States,
but around the world as well
on the African continent,
in areas of the world in which
cell phones are relatively new.
But thanks to the,
uh,
unbelievable power of mobile devices
basically can be taken anywhere.
And what we've learned in
all of those countries,
whether it be in the most advanced
cities in the United States and India,
or whether it be an in the most remote
areas across the African continent or in
Latin America, what we've learned, um,
rather than the question
that we've asked though is,
is how can mobile computing
really transform healthcare?
And what we've learned is that it
can do so in three different ways.
So specifically, um, what I'm
going to posit here today and, and,
and the, the requests that I'm going to
end up making at the end of this is that
specifically mobile computing can
help three means of intervention for
healthcare. It can help in one
identifying patients at risk. In our case,
because we're still use cervical
cancer as our, as our case study here,
it can identify women at risk too.
It can ensure that a poor appropriate
treatment is applied and three is that it
can show unsure adherence.
They can make sure that the woman who
was told that she's positive is treated
correctly and then it's followed up
with correctly so that cancer doesn't
continue to become an issue.
So let's go into those three quickly.
First it can. I, uh, mobile computing
can help identify women at risk.
This is a scatter plot of data that was,
uh,
was analyzed as part of a Kaggle
hosted competition that Genentech,
a large pharmaceutical company made
available using symphony's data sets,
symphonies, a large data aggregator
here in the United States.
And what the competition requested was
for data science teams to look at this
large public data set and identify
based on this large public data set,
which women are at risk
for cervical cancer.
And they found an accuracy of,
I think it's over 90% and identifying high
risk women just from public data sets.
Now why is this important?
Well,
because the United States spends about
six point $6 billion every year screening
women for cervical cancer,
six point $6 billion.
55 million women are screened every
year and yet 10 million women are not.
And out of those 55 million women,
only 30 million women
should actually be screened.
Okay.
So you're basically screening 25 million
women who do not need to be screened
and you're not screening 10 million
women at highest risk that do need to be
screened.
And that's why African American and
Hispanic women in the United States have
rates of cervical cancer that are almost
equivalent in some places higher than
women in Africa and
women in Latin America.
Because we're not screening the women
that need to be screened and we're
overscreening the women that
don't need to be screened.
That's just the data issue.
It's just the data problem.
It's something that can be
rather straight forward solve.
And once you have that information and
you can reallocate resources accordingly
and you ensure that the right care
is going to the right patients,
then you can make the right decisions
as to who needs to be taken care of.
So that first one is just identifying
the women that need to be screened.
The second one is applying
the appropriate treatment.
This is the basic workflow
for how cervical cancer
screening works in the United
States today. And it's the same thing with
the pap smear as well as the HPV test.
So let's go through it rather quickly.
Woman comes into a doctor's office,
she lies on the table, the providers
scrape, sells off the cervix,
puts a little bucket, closes that
bucket, gives us a medical assistant.
Medical assistant, takes it and
brings it into the front corner.
They call logistics company logistics
company comes in, picks up the buckets,
takes them to a lab lab than unloads it,
brings it to the technician,
technician then takes it,
stains it after they stay in it,
they didn't take it and
put it under a microscope.
They look under the microscope or they
look under it as part of an essay to look
whether there is presence
of HPV DNA there.
Then identify whether or not that woman
has had something that is high risk.
They then write that down. That then gets
oftentimes faxed back to the provider.
The medical assistant takes that facts,
looks at the medical record types and
information into the medical record.
If it's positive,
then it goes and talks to the doctor,
the doctor that it needs
to make a decision. Hm,
maybe I'll call back that patient. And
then the medical assistant calls up the,
the patient and the patient three weeks
later after she had that test taken,
needs to be rescheduled.
Little Bit complicated, right?
So that tire period of time for those
three weeks after a patient has come in
and gotten the test taken,
she doesn't know.
And oftentimes wage workers role,
Americans,
single parents have a
hard time of scheduling.
That next fall they just moved mountains
to be able to have their annual
physical. So they get a call and they say
to and and the medical assistant says,
listen ma'am, you've gotten a positive
pap smear. And the woman says, all right,
I'll, I'll, I'll call you back when
I can reschedule. I'm at work now.
And then she has a million things
that she needs to do when she forgets.
And that's why I added the six point
$6 billion that we spend every year
screening women in the United States.
1.2 billion of that are due
to nonadherence to women
that are lost to followup
because she wasn't able to
schedule that next visit in time.
And then she comes back the next year
and she's positive again and she says,
Oh God,
you told me last year I was positive.
And then they need to schedule
again but they don't all come.
And so that long process leads to women
going from the life column to the death
calm.
Now what we're doing at mobile and it
is what we've found is that you can
replace that whole process of collecting
the sample, sending it to the lab,
and then bring in the woman back for
the next step through applying pretty
fundamental machine learning algorithms
to the images that you capture using a
colposcope.
So there's some fascinating groundbreaking
work that will be published pretty
shortly that I'm not allowed
to talk about too much,
but I'll try to share the basics of in
which the National Cancer Institute and
the National Library of medicine have
done extraordinary work to prove that our
partners that global good have been
able to identify cervical cancer with an
accuracy pretty high,
a little over 90% just
on a single image alone.
And that is extraordinary because what
that means is that while the woman's in
the clinic without her going and going
through that entire process and 0.6
seconds, she can go from the
death column to the life calm.
And that's just the beginning,
right?
Because what's fascinating
is that these algorithms,
because remember cervical cancer,
just like many other diseases,
visually assessable,
these algorithms and we already know and
love and a deploy on an almost everyday
basis,
many of you in this room probably write
those algorithms and they're based on
cafe, on tensor flow. Now we're moving
towards tensorflow lite. There's simple,
straightforward machine learning problems.
Interestingly enough,
computer vision didn't
really cut it there,
but when you build a
large enough data set,
and currently mobile Ott is proud to
have large data sets in the world on
cervical cancer,
you can use that to identify disease at
its earliest stages using nothing more
than a visual image. So that that has to
do with applying appropriate treatment.
Because if you can apply that treatment
on the point of care at that moment when
the woman's in the room,
you can do so much more for
that woman than anything else.
But then once you apply that term and
you need to make sure that she's actually
taken care of, right? So
the patient examination,
which most medical devices do pretty well,
is only a very small link in the chain
to ensure the patients are kept healthy
because after that woman is examined and
we need to communicate with that woman
what it was that was seen and what
it is that she needs to do and if the
appropriate treatment isn't there.
If it's not for cervical cancer or it
could be for any other type of disease,
she needs to be referred
and once she's referred,
then we need to make sure that we
update her record because if we're not
expressing to the other person
what it is that you saw,
then they might miss
it because in the end,
clinicians are only human right and they
only know what to look for if they're
told what to look for.
Again,
it's a problem of data and once that
patient record is updated and the provider
provides the appropriate treatment,
then you want to take that information
and you want to warehouse it because you
want to have information about how disease
spreads within a population. Remember,
cervical cancer is a communicable disease.
It comes from the human papilloma virus
and there's so many other diseases like
that.
If you can find trends,
you can know how to allocate resources
effectively and then once you have that
data,
you can start identifying patients and
then once you identify those patients and
you need to examine them,
and that continuum is what makes
healthcare and that continuum is a data
problem.
It's a communication problem.
It's a problem that we've
solved in social networks,
but we haven't yet solved in healthcare,
but we can now.
So for that there are three things that
to close off the more frontal part of
this and to start our conversation,
there are three things
that I would ask of you.
Have all of you here and all of you that
you know that have those super powers
that you're applying at Google and that
you're applying in all of your work
outside of it.
First is let's,
let's help us, let's help the healthcare
system identify patients at risk, right?
Let's take public data sets and identify
how we can more clearly map vectors and
then express that information to health
care organizations so that they can
deploy the proper resources and the most
effective and efficient manner so that
those healthcare organizations can do
what they do best and care for patients.
Let's also apply the
appropriate treatment devices.
Have a huge amount of data exhaust and
obviously if you have garbage coming in,
you have garbage coming out.
And that's why for mobility tea,
we believe that the critical component
is ensuring that you have control over
the type of information that comes in
so that you can apply the appropriate
information that comes out for analysis.
So let's connect more
devices to the cloud.
Do it with all the proper unnecessary
security precautions to ensure the patient
privacy is kept,
but you identify a woman from her cervix,
nor can you identify a man from
his or for annual cancer or uh,
or any person from their,
uh, from their skin disease.
Let's use that information so that
any provider, anywhere, any nurse,
any midwife, any technician that can take
a mobile phone and bring it into the,
into the field,
let's make sure that every member of
humanity has the same access to the same
high level diagnostic accuracy just by
ensuring that they all have access to the
right information. And then
finally, let's ensure adherence.
We've learned so much about
social dynamics over the
past decade alone and yet
we're not doing a very good job of
ensuring that that woman that gets called
[inaudible] told that she
has high grade precancer,
we're not doing the job,
bring her back.
How is it that we're able to get her
to order stuff on, on, on online shops,
but we're not able to get her to come
back to a clinic or get the clinic to her.
We understand the social costs of
having mothers die in their, in their,
in their most important ages.
Let's intervene.
So figuring out how to do that, that's,
that's a data problem. And so the,
the key,
the key here is to do the examination,
the analysis and enable the
action immediately at the
point of care to do that
calculation fast to do it
wherever it is that that happens,
that the patient is to bring health
care to wherever the sick are.
And that's where mobile devices are so
powerful because they go wherever we are
and almost every person
on the planet now has one.
Now we're doing our part mobility t by
taking the same technology that sits at
the heart of this device,
enabling a mobile phone to be turned
into a medical device and applying it in
other diseases that are
visually assessable.
Anything that you can identify with your
eye that a clinician identifies from
endoscopic procedures to,
to skin,
you should be able to do with a mobile
device. You just need to tweak it.
So using the right optics,
the right illumination, the
right structures and so on.
But there's so many other ways to do it.
And we're hoping that every device
company, that every technology provider,
we'll start thinking about how they can
use their core resources to ensure that
their technologies are being used
to save lives at the point of care.
And just the last thought,
once again,
is that data is critical and it's the
mobile element that enables that data to
be actionable.
So all of us here have that
native understanding just
because we use our phones
every day.
So let's use them for something that
ends up saving a life that might be
otherwise lost.
Thank you all very much and I hope
that you join us in making healthcare
accessible to every person on the planet.
And I welcome your questions.
So there are two, uh, I was asked to
say there are two microphones, uh,
there are eliminated by the spotlights.
If you have any question at all,
I'd be happy to answer them. Um,
and no question. Is that a balance?
Hi, thanks a lot for the talk.
Um, so I have two questions. Um,
the first is you mentioned the
accuracy is around like, uh,
a little bit higher than 90%.
Can you talk about like
maybe the breakdown of that
in the sense of are there
false positives or false negatives?
Absolutely. So, um,
there are a number of papers
that I could refer you to the,
the seminal paper that will be coming
out soon. We'll break down a lot further.
What,
what I can say about it is that what's
fascinating about the cervix is that it's
a,
a pretty clear example of
squamous cell carcinoma,
which means that as the
cells start to proliferate,
they start to show visibility.
Now you will get false negatives,
but the sensitivity and
specificity are both above 90,
which means that you will know that you're
seeing something and you will more or
less know that that thing
is cancer right now.
To compare that to the pap smear to HPV,
HPV,
Katcha HPV testing catches a ton of
people who have the higher restrain that
will never develop into cancer because
only 5% of the people who have a high
restraint of HPV actually will
end up developing the cancer.
And the test just looks for
the strain of HPV DNA. Right?
What a visual examination does is it
looks for when the cells are already
growing and that's when you want to, you
want to, you want to nip the bud, right?
You want to take away those cells
where the infection occurs. And in,
as far as the literature shows, now
around 97% of cases, it'll never reinfect.
Thank you.
Um, and I guess the second
question, this is, I'm, um,
so the common, um, I guess
barrier with healthcare is,
um, sort of gaining access to data
primarily because of privacy issues. Yeah.
Um, can you, like,
you mentioned that there's like a large
database that you're probably using to
train the algorithm.
Can you talk maybe about like what
has been done in that end? Like how,
what's the current status?
And I'm like, how are the,
uh, healthcare providers
like responding to, um,
to a need for technology companies to
have access to that data so that we can
help them?
Yeah. So first of all, it's, it's a
fascinating challenge. I just came, we,
one of the, um, one of the, uh,
organizational networks that we work
with are the Centers for disease control.
The CDC and I just came from
a conference in Atlanta.
The CDC is informatics
conference. And, um,
one of the things that I learned there
was that even within the healthcare
system,
even within the CDC,
one organization to have significant
challenges sharing information,
right? And it's, it's,
it's one of the ironies of the day where
we can track almost every human on the
planet. We know where they're going and
what they're eating and we're, you know,
what they're doing more or less,
but we can't keep them healthy because
the information that we get from
healthcare providers, this
is all walked up, right?
The way we address it just
by building our own database.
So every time that
somebody uses our system,
we have that information and it's de
identified and we structured our database
in silos. And so any one of
those pieces of information,
every one of those tables has a
different lookup function. And so you,
you can't really get the information
about who the patient is with information
on what the provider thinks with the
rumors about who the provider is with
information about what the
resulting diagnosises, right.
So you have the ability to structure it.
So any one of those pieces
is de identified by nature.
And what we're hoping is that,
and I know that Google is involved in
this and a number of other organizations,
this is what we're hoping is that these
standards will start to propagate.
That is every piece of equipment that
is somehow digitally connected should
enable others to learn from it and to
integrate it and to build through it
solutions. And, and I, I've been,
I've been very surprised for the good
and for the bad about how that works
within different healthcare systems.
Um, so, you know, you have some of the,
the more, uh, so we work in, we
work in countries where, you know,
the, basically there are no land lines,
you know, everything is mobile phones and,
and, and there are countries
like that that, um,
that some of them are very comfortable
with the cloud and some of them,
even though their data center
is literally, you know,
an open shack with that that
sometimes gets rained on,
they want things to be hosted locally.
But thanks to containerization, you,
you can do that, right? If you
build a proper microservices
architecture, you can,
you can make it work. Um, so I
think that we're going to get there,
but we just need to get more people to
sign on to interoperability standards and
we need to ensure that people recognize
that this literally has to do with
saving lives.
And so delaying is costing lives,
I guess as a followup
park. Um, so what, um,
if you are collecting that information,
there's always that fear of your data
being misused or being identified.
So I guess even for me, if I were to go
through this, it would be like, all right,
like how do I know that there's no one
that does a neat to see this data will
not, will not see this
data. So on your end,
what do you do to protect the
data that you're collecting?
Yeah,
so first of all,
it's what's called secondary use data
by nature because no one other than your
provider has the information of who
you are and what the examination is.
So we cannot be identified
by our cervix or by image,
depends on what images of
our skin, but you know, you,
you cannot be identified by it.
It's just not,
there aren't public data sets available
to ensure that kind of identification of
a person based on one mole or, or on
a cervix or an oral cavity even. Um,
and so because of that,
you know,
the image and the annotation
is did edified by nature.
So there's no risk from that perspective
that a woman would be identified. Um,
but yeah,
we need to structure correctly.
And so when we structured our
database from the very beginning,
we made sure that there was,
that you literally needed to,
they had a salt and a house lookup table
between the different tables to make
sure that in any which case you'd have
to kind of connect so many different
pieces of data in order
to re identify someone.
But you just don't give people the
keys so you don't make that available.
Oh, thank you. Of course. Absolutely.
Okay.
Yeah. Hi, thanks for the
talk. So the question might
be out of scope of this talk,
but it's still,
do you know of any efforts where machine
learning is used to diagnose cancer or
other diseases?
Um,
based on other kinds of images like
Mri scans or CT scans? What are those?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, so
first of all there was a,
there's now a tremendous amount of
information being made publicly available
around the world. Thanks. The national
governments and large healthcare system.
So I just heard that,
uh,
the National Institutes of health just
published a huge data set of MRI based
images.
Um,
I know I just heard from a friend of mine
here that you can all speak with after
that his father in law is
doing some exceptional work.
I'm down at Hopkins and identifying cancer
in its earliest stages and colorectal
or pancreatic, pancreatic
cancer. Um, so there, there,
there's more and more information
becoming available, right? And,
and that's critical. So I think that
the, the, the, the real goal has,
and this is where I'm going to
speak for my thesis, so, so,
so my thesis is that smart devices
are gonna make the difference.
So data sets are great, but as
all of you were, engineer's,
no data set is only good so far as the
source of that data is reproducible.
So if the data set,
if you have a data set,
but the way of collecting the data
changes than the type of analysis that you
had, the class are you built based on the
earlier data may not be relevant for a
future, uh, for future data. And
so one of the things that we,
we believe as a company is that tying
the data to the device and ensuring that
as a full solution you can control
the way you bring data and the way you
annotate that data and the way you
analyze that data and that becomes a,
a a virtuous cycle.
Then you can really provide Karen.
So more and more companies are
starting to recognize that as well.
Ge has a huge initiative around
it. I know that others also, um,
and I think that as people start thinking
about medicine as the application of
expertise and devices and an extension
of the ability to provide medicine,
then we'll see more and more of that.
So there is scanned,
I mean I think Google did
a project on the eyes.
There is a MRI scans, CT
scans and, and others. And,
and what I find very fascinating
is that, um, that it,
for the past 20 years there've been
different approaches that mainly use
computer vision.
Um,
but really where the breakthrough is
business and applying really standard off
the shelf models. And I'll give you an
example. That might be a little crude,
but it's interesting because
it was just fascinating.
So it took us a pretty long time to
develop an algorithm that can kind of
identify the cervix. And then some
of you will know that there's a,
there's a show on HBO show called Silicon
Valley. They, that, um, open source the,
or at least gave a walkthrough of how
they created an algorithm for hot dog,
not hot dog. We took that hot
dog, not hotdog instruction.
And within three days we built
an algorithm that was cervix,
not a cervix in three days.
It took us like a year to do it before.
And then with the new tools that literally
just became open, it took three days.
And that exponential,
I mean a lot of arrhythmic shift in terms
of speed and potential is astronaut.
It's just, it's crazy. Right?
And it also makes sense and this
is one of the things that you know,
that that's why the,
you know,
your superpowers is engineers
are so critical here because um,
what is fascinating is that,
um,
you have here a a moment in which,
we knew for,
for all of history,
we knew that human beings have the
ability to perceive information and to use
our brains in order to find patterns
in that information and then to make
decisions, right? I mean,
that's what medicine is.
Medicine is where you have a person
who's, you know, a magician, so to speak,
a doctor who goes through many years
of school in order to learn all the
different things they need to learn,
they get to that point of care and they
make very educated guesses as to what to
look for based on what they see.
They referenced information that they've
learned to make certain decisions.
And then based on the decisions they make,
the person either lives or dies. Right?
Well,
algorithms can see tens of thousands of
more patients than doctors ever could
just because they can literally
reviewed tens of thousand more patients.
So now we have the ability to actually
do what the doctor doctors have done in a
way that we simply couldn't before.
Yeah.
This,
the anonymized data collected
by two mobile order duty.
Um, um, I was able to, with our
people to a shutdown Lord our, uh,
is our proprietary.
So we do have a data set that we
made available through Kaggle, uh,
in a competition that Intel
sponsored on type of cervix,
which is critical for treatment.
Uh,
we're going to be making more and more
data available to the research community
and we're,
we're very excited to work with folks,
so please feel free to contact me
at anytime and I'd be happy to,
to share information.
Um,
and on a similar note to have you taught
is using this device has as a means to
collect art to collect data on
all the other sorts of tabs.
You use an image to the IRS.
Yes.
So we already have the ability to do into
scopic procedure is oral. Absolutely.
Which is critical. Absolutely
critical. Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. Hi. Um, I would just look a little
clarity on how exactly the product works.
So I saw a photo with what looked
like an attachment sort of scope,
sweat for Server Kush
answers specifically.
Are you taking images
from the pap smear swab?
No.
So I,
I usually don't show it cause it's a
little more graphic for people who aren't
aware.
A woman will lie on the
table and something called
a speculum is inserted just
like inserted today to take a pap
smear or a colposcopy. And our device,
which is classified as a colposcope,
which is a long range microscope
to look at the cervix,
the vagina and the vulva
is placed at a distance.
It never touches the patient and at a
distance it images the cervix and based on
what it sees and what the provider sees,
they make certain decisions.
So at this moment and what the providers
are doing is using this as a long range
microscope to look at the
patient and based on what
they see they make decisions.
And over time,
as we start to provide more and more
guideline interventions and workflow
interventions, it will also
guide them to do more and more.
And so one of the things that
we've, the, so for example, um,
we have a wonderful partner in the
rotary club in San Diego and they built a
partnership between,
uh,
the Jalala about hospital in Afghanistan
and scripts medical center in San Diego.
And the first cervical cancer screening
program in Afghanistan was started
because eva systems out in Afghanistan
were being used by midwives and a
gynecologist and San Diego was watching
what they were doing and providing them
with tips on how to actually
perform the examination.
Thank you.
Absolute pleasure.
Thanks again for the talk.
Have you found cultural barriers in terms
of using the actual device and if so,
how do you overcome those?
How do you do education so that the
women who are receiving care feel
comfortable with the idea of a
more complex device being used?
Sure. Um, so first of all, what's been,
mm hmm.
We've found amazing universality
and certain elements that
we had not previously
expected. Um, so the first,
there are cultural differences in
terms of insertion of a speculum.
A speculum insertion is problematic in
certain places and for obvious reasons.
Um, once you get past that hurdle,
which has nothing to do with us,
then it's pretty straight forward.
It's just the visualization and any place
in which a speculum is inserted there
used to a woman visualizing them.
Um,
what's been fascinating
actually culturally is that
what we noticed the first
than Kenya proved to be
correct also around the world,
which is that women loved seeing an
image of their cervix because women had
never seen their cervix.
And remember in emerging markets,
in rural areas and Roisin in America,
cervical cancer is a
leading cause of death.
So they will know a woman who
has died and cervical cancer.
So they hear again and again that this
something they shouldn't be worried about,
but they don't know what it is.
And so to be able to turn around and say,
this is what I saw,
look right here,
you have to go and get
this treated was huge.
And as part of the interview
is one of the woman called it.
I saw my cervical selfie right there.
They had this, this moment where it was,
it was very empowering for her to see what
she looks like on the inside and, and,
and in doing so reduce that, that fear
barrier. So I think that that's critical.
I think it's critical across all of
healthcare that is, you know, in the end,
health care has to do with the
person, the patient, right.
So we met many times medical
device companies, um,
think of healthcare in
a very abstract form.
And that has to do with providers and
payers and institutions and networks.
It has to do about that woman,
that one woman,
and that one woman needs to own her
health because if she doesn't take care of
herself, no matter how much the health
care system is developed and robust,
she'll die.
Cool. Thanks very much. Absolute pleasure.
So we'll take one more question and then
we'll, we'll start to wrap up. Yeah.
Um, so my question is more
on a marketing standpoint.
So who is your target that you're going
to words and trying to sell this to?
Like are you allowed to say how much it
costs or is that something that you're
keeping under wraps right now?
Um,
but just more of a marketing
where you're trying to go to,
is it hospitals are different
organizations and stuff? Sure. That
so mobile Ott works primarily with health
care networks and hospital networks.
Um, although obviously the
person who uses it as a,
a nurse or a midwife or
a gynecologist there,
procurement officer is generally
the person who purchases it. Um,
in the United States, we sell
them for 4,000, $800 each for,
for this generation, um, which is about
20% of the price of a traditional unit.
And the goal is for price to
never be a barrier, right?
We want to make sure that every provider
and every corner of America and the
world pricing obviously is lower globally.
We'll be able to provide the care that
they're called to provide when they
provide it. And there was a, there
was a slide here that I wanted a,
I'll show you in a second,
which is important for us from a marketing
perspective. Um, the woman here, the,
the, the icon here, that's,
that's who we call eva,
just like the product's called Eva.
That's Eva. And Eva is who we engage with.
Eva is the care worker or the
nurse, the midwife, the technician,
that woman that serves Dan Knight
to serve the majority of humanity.
And we seek to work with
her. So from a, from a,
from a basic service perspective,
our goal is to provide that person with
a tool she needs and we'll work with her
healthcare system,
with our hospital network to give her the
tools she needs to provide care to our
patients.
Pleasure.
So I'll just, I'll wrap up, um, on a,
on a very basic request from all of you.
So I'm on,
you know, when, uh, when I was
given the opportunity to, to,
to come here and thank you, Elana
again for making it possible. Uh,
the thing that kept on going
through my mind was how, uh, uh,
to use a lack of a better term,
how pregnant with potential,
um, this organization,
Google and companies it are for impacting
the very fundamentals of healthcare
lessons that we have learned over the
past decade and how to identify individual
support.
Those individuals through choices ensure
that they get to the right information
at the right time with the right
people are lessons that are immediately
applicable to every person on the planet.
And Mobile Ott can only do its part in it.
And hopefully we'll continue to
strengthen the way that providers provide
healthcare.
Organizations such as yours and
others in your peer group have so much
opportunity to be able to fundamentally
affect a human condition on whether a
person lives in other year or just not.
And so I,
I hope that you could
use your superpowers,
whether it be from marketing to business
to engineering to ensure that no
person, no woman, no child, no father,
no a man dies of an easily
preventable disease.
Again,
thank you very much.